nowadays it seems like everyone is
making millions of dollars a year
selling feed picks so we're heading the
streets of Miami asking how much money
do you make a year oh [__] I think this
year is going to be like 200 but it's
only cuz I didn't make money for like
the first 6 months profit or Revenue
like we're not coping here right profit
profit profit what do you do what
industry I sell dick pills oh is that
actually what you sell the Ron Jeremy
pills I have yeah yeah give me like an
example of like an email or something
like what are some tactics you put You'
be like bro you ever see those those
headlines on like like weird sites that
you probably shouldn't be on where it's
like this one weird trick in so you run
ads on on the Hub run I don't run but
there's someone on your team running ads
on the Hub they're not on my team
they're on the Brand's team holy [__] I
just I just you just write emails yeah
basically I do that too what are your
tips for someone wanting to get start in
the selling um pichad do pills I would
say don't do it like find something else
it's honestly it's pretty hard it's
harder than you think pause
yo but yeah yeah like it's I mean you
have to like be pretty good at writing
don't do it find something else get a
real job do you think that selling
supplements and and [__] like that is
unethical or you think it's cool yeah
some of them are unethical and it just
happens that the unethical ones kind of
pay pretty good yeah yeah that's the way
a lot of stuff goes do they work though
some of them there's a there's a few
that I've like not bought but heavily
considered buying after reading what I
wrote about it I've never used any of
those one of my buddies has a [__]
Banger one Banger what I forget what
it's called it's called like rou oh okay
okay you're talking about no no no yeah
it's like n but apparent it's fire for
those of you guys wondering supplements
are [__] do not buy a don't they're
actually no they're actually nonsense
like everyone I know that sells
supplements it's all just branding and
marketing do not buy that [__] agreed
and you sell them oh dude yeah and
honestly that whole pink salt thing for
the for the gym Bros in the comments
regular salt is better really yeah it's
just the same [__] like somebody like me
went on a podcast if you can just do a
little bit of Tik Tok marketing then you
can uh sell whatever the [__] you want
you can print Millions by selling not
dick pills something else yeah find
something good and then promote it on
Tik Tok that's the real that's the real
wave it is if you want to make a bunch
of money promote stuff on Tik Tok bro I
know a bunch of people printing with
like affiliate [__] that's what I do is
like I I do short for marketing and I
teach other people and stuff and then we
provide our students with like affiliate
opportunities so like if you weren't
like a dick pill brand we would come and
be like we'll give you know we'll make
like a marketing plan give it to our
students and they can push your product
if you guys want to join and be able to
affiliate for products and learn how to
go viral yourself the Link's at the top
of the description as well how much
money do you make a year about uh 500
500k profit about uh 200k 200k profit
yeah what industry are you in
advertising advertising everyone just
says advertising marketing like what
does that mean what do you actually do I
do Tik Tok you do Tik Tok I do Tik Tok
for my clients for Brands I do
influencer marketing are you serious
yeah I do wow no like no offense I've
just never seen like older people
getting into like Tik Tok marketing I
mean anyone can do it like it's great
yeah I work I work in social media for
the last 15 years so like I have a lot
of experience in Instagram Tik Tok and
everything wow and why Tik Tok because
it's what is the most it's get most of
people's attention right now yeah it's
the easiest way always focus on what
getting more people attention what are
your biggest tips for people looking to
get into Tik Tok Marketing in this kind
of business to be authentic to betic to
be authentic and to have like a Brands
Partnerships that make sense so for a
influencer or some a Creator they need
to use the brand by thems before they go
forward to make a partnership of the
brand so basically build up your brand
before you sell a product is that what
you're saying yes that's the best that's
the best way I agree you don't want to
be selling stuff right away answer a
quick question for a
video how much money do you make a year
you got the chains on you got some new
bags like 20,000 20,000 yeah that sounds
about right what do you do for a living
Waste Management no I'm working in a
hotel you work in a hotel yeah any side
hustles yeah are you allowed to talk
about them on YouTube no all right are
you in the mafia am I in the what
whatever you want to call it how you
doing the mom was just standing staring
at me got give how you down okay Indians
let's do it how much money do you make a
year between 50 to 60k 50 to 60k yeah I
think you're one of the first like
honest people tonight 60k 60k what do
you guys do we are Tax Consultants what
are you uh accountants accountants yep
both of you what's your plan to get rich
what's like the take you to a
millionaire plan you have one um not
sure not really not yet no buy a lot of
Jordans and then sell it for higher
price buy a lot of Jordans and sell it
for higher price yeah okay okay where
you guys from uh we are from India but
we work in the Bahamas you work in the
Bahamas that's not that's not too bad of
a setup eh that's not too shvy how is it
coming from India and making it out I
know a lot of guys are still there just
doing like remote work for really cheap
let's work more money L's work more
money my need to add subtitles for that
one I need someone that's as patient as
me what's up
espol
col
the Dr drones drones
like oh
okay Instagram Instagram
F marketing it's
big ex me ladies you want to answer a
quick
question okay okay sorry that's how you
get like a tate thrown in jail case
they're like ah myad done all right
let's go to the other side of the mall
yo how much money do you make a year
nobody wants to answer that yo how much
money do you make a year 20,000 20,000
how much how much money do you make a
year too much yeah all right ready ready
ready ready ready
gmen bro usually it's like you give like
a gmen back you look pissed like black
people see another black guy and they're
like hey and I'm like see a Giants fan
you're like Gman you know I don't know
maybe I'm just [__] I wonder that a
lot how much money do you make a year
how much do I make a Year Uncle Sam's
not listening right uh he's not
listening he's not listen in Monopoly
money how much money how much year do
you make a year in Monopoly money money
um I'm I'm up there in a lot of those
figures like
z0000 Z something like that it's it's
six seven figures something like that
there are a lot of figures yes amount of
figures all right what do you do for
work I own a private investigative and
security company so like if someone
breaks into my home and the police are
eating donuts and being fat asses I hit
you up yeah I I'll actually um go in and
eat some donuts with them as I make
money but we will also vacate the
premises do you have to do like
marketing for your business or is it
mainly Word of Mouth where you do a good
job and then both both both Intel yeah
marketing and Word of Mouth word of
mouth is is very big in my business once
you're doing excellent service yeah can
you tell me one good story from your
business I feel like you have to have
like a like a ton of them but give me
like one good one I had a guy that uh
well young lady suspected um her husband
was cheating on
her and come to find out her husband was
cheating with
a
guy not only a guy oh I'm on the money
but it was with her
sister's brother yo that's [__] up
different fathers was wicked is this
happened like maybe a month ago what do
you do when you find that out is it like
in the movies where you're like you know
what I there's like that great and then
how do you tell them like what the I
mean it's it's a paid job I mean we what
we do is we we give the information to
the client and they deal with it from
there we there's videos pictures and uh
whatever they ask for actually it's it's
this what we do yo that's crazy with a
guy wait and he was it was with the guy
and the the sister yeah the sister's
brother wow people do some weird [__]
behind the scenes you would be amazed
who's watching you when you don't think
they're watching you how long have you
been doing it like a year and you
already up to 600,000 yeah man that's
like short form marketing Tik Tok how
are you doing Tik Tok we're crushing man
we're at like over a billion views total
on the brand right now yeah so if any of
you guys want to make money with
clipping videos we have a program inside
of my Discord where you can join and
learn all about that I have a whole free
video course for you guys maybe I need
to have my son reach out to your page
he's a he's an aspiring artist can you
take a picture of me I'm throwing this
on my uh my
Tinder every basic [__] takes that same
picture look at we got more of them
that's the classic that's the that's the
classic right there we have a wild white
boy with his girl and typically the mous
species doesn't want to admit he doesn't
make as much money as he does so we're
going to go investigate excuse me sir do
you mind answering a really quick
question for a video how much money do
you make a year uh I'm not currently
working I'm currently University what do
you want to do for business when you get
older and whatnot like what's the plan
to get rich no idea no clue genuinely no
clue you guys have any ideas business
business yeah like any like you want to
start a business do you want to like
type [__] type [__] I [__] with the
spatula the spatula yeah it's a nice
spatula it's good it's nice it's really
nice what about you guys like stay stay
at home moms or Boss [__] make all the
money excuse me boss [__] make all the
money yes okay yeah seconded we get that
a lot nowadays do you want a boss [__]
wife or a stay-at Home wife that's a
ridiculous question right I'm just
starting beef right now I know you're
just Prime instigation right here oh
come on now yeah exactly what about you
what about you everyone knows my take
like what what is it what is it of
course you got like I make all the money
and then you have like The Ting stay at
home is that crazy just it's just like
old time stereotypical would you say you
a feminist oh yeah I love women I want
to be the boss [__] I want to be the
boss I want to Peg my husband am I the
only one how much money do you make a
year a good bit a bunch of money just
know that does he need money to get you
no no got me since day W so you've been
since day one hell yeah that's the goal
bro that's the goal what industry are
you in uh salesman like what do you say
uh Office Furniture Home Furniture uh
home appliances do you work at a store
and sell the customers that come in or
you do it digitally yeah I have my uh
own warehouse and um yeah basically
started from scrap started with a small
space uh 500 square ft and I just build
it up slowly how old are you 22 nice bro
keep crushing it do you guys do any
content or anything for your business uh
no we don't I don't actually but I
should get on that cuz that's that's
where it's at right now marketing bro
short for marketing is the wave right
now marketing is T [__] you know I'm say
how much money do you make a year 0 0
yeah how is it dating a man that makes 0
it's amazing because I don't have to
worry about anything all that money off
shore that's what I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about
CH all right it's not about the money he
makes it's about the Personality yeah
you tell them yeah so just stick to the
personality and maybe the money will
come yeah we need you as like the new
like first lady or something yeah one
day Shelly I'll be the president of
America yeah this whole world will be
raised under
me excuse me excuse me sir would you
mind answering a quick question for a
video i' love to get your uh advice on
something a [__] damn it is there any
way that I can take a photo with you oh
I [__] love you I'm Turkish Asam Alum
oh you watch the Muslim videos that's
awesome bro what do you guys do for work
only fans only fans I'm an actor and a
musician what kind of actor an only fans
actor no I'm a real actor like in the
big one of the biggest movies coming out
January um February 14th really Marley
yeah oh you're in the Bob Marley movie
how much money do you make a year doing
what you do it's a lot of money man I
can't disclose that at the moment to be
honest but just disclose how do you how
do you do on only fans you're crushing
it yeah I crushing it I make like a mill
like a mill like a month or a year year
nice do you like do you like doing only
fans yeah pays the bills pays the bills
what do your parents think of you doing
only fans they don't know what they
don't know won't hurt them what if they
see one of your Tik toks or something
see this video they might now they know
I just tell them like just
relax they're put up so they're rich
they're not aome what do they think you
do if you like give them money um I
don't really know we're on a don't ask
on tell Paces so okay fair
enough I do only EV decent amount of
cappers tonight but overall we got some
great interviews make sure you join the
sunny F Discord join Faz growth to learn
how you can go viral with short form we
provide you with affiliate opportunities
it's a great way to make make some extra
income and whatnot and yeah see you in
the next video make sure to hit the bell
and stuff YouTube has been railing me
with Shadow bands lately so hit the Bell
don't miss the videos they're all
bangers peace